avec une cinquantaine de chantiers
prévus pour les deux prochaines années
les cons orange ne sont pas près de
disparaître à montréal il y aura des
impacts c'est sûr il y aura dès qu'on
arrange c'est certain certains chantiers
se termine enfin
c'est le cas de l'échangeur turcot par
contre d'autres vont s'intensifier au
tunnel louis-hippolyte-lafontaine 2021
et marquée par une série de travaux
préparatoires
cette année nous allons réaliser les
voies réservées les stationnements
incitatifs c'est en 2022 que les
véritables entraves dans le tunnel vont
commencer une voie sera retranchée dans
chaque direction
il y aura toujours deux voies de
circulation le dans chacune des
directions
québec va refaire ou si la chaussée en
béton de l'autoroute 40 en direction est
entre sainte anne de bellevue et qu'un
clown on lance ou si la reconstruction
du pont de l'île-aux-tourtes à l'ouest
de l'île ou un corridor sera préservé en
vue d'y intégrer éventuellement une
solution de transport collectif
pour ce qui est du ram de l'est la
ministre le répète il sera en hauteur
l'europe de l'est est un projet
signature et oui québec tient toujours à
la ligne bleue la ligne bleue qui est
vraiment je vous le répète une grande
priorité pour nous mais l'arrivée du rem
de l'est force une révision de certains
aspects de la ligne bleue et si vincent
maisonneuve radio canada montréal